whatever impact my work has is it's
either its comic relief or it's crap
maybe mental liberation somewhat in that
I see these poems as little acts of
travel or little acts of imaginative
journeying or looking through the woods
for something and finding a clearing at
the end of the poem and to be able to
take people on that little ride I
imagine it's pleasurable for them
because it gives pleasure for me and
since I'm the first one to take the ride
I figure maybe others will enjoy it too
but I don't see any I don't see any
impact beyond that but you don't I don't
think you can think about that and still
write or still play or whatever your
form of expression is you do it and then
it falls into the world and it the fact
that the world doesn't completely ignore
it is probably enough of a enough
feedback for one first of all I'm not a
terribly unhappy that poetry has a small
audience this is not something that
keeps me up at night one of the reasons
it has a small audience is that there's
a lot of unreadable poetry being written
so it's I don't see it as the fault of a
Philistine poetry hating barbarian
public I think it's just as much the
fault of poets who ignore their readers
and write either indulge in in
self-expression period and that it's a
highly rated overrated activity because
no one really cares about you stranger
or they write terribly obscure riddle
type poetry and many times you get a
vicious combination of self-expression
and obscurity no so who would want to
read it in the first place and like like
jazz or or like chamber music we're like
keeping tropical fish poetry has a
fairly small but very intense audience
and often the small of the smaller the
audience the more intense there are the
participants feel about this interest I
mean you can compare that to television
it has a broad audience but I don't
think anyone cares very intensely about
it they just watch